I'm your host Lana Galera and I'm joined
right now with a fear the walking dead
cat hi guys okay well first off Garrett
Jenna Maggie
welcome to comic-con how's it been for
you guys is this your first time here
experiencing the walking dead craziness
it's my first time sorry my first time
for Walking Dead absolutely first time
at comic-con I've been a few times for
other shows but not nothing is great at
this nothing is as great as this this is
very true The Walking Dead has such a
devoted fan base so to secure the
Walking Dead what has it been like
specially for you for in the back coming
on to the show
what is the fan reaction been like for
you it's been remarkably kind of
positive supportive people are kind of
excited by the possibilities really I
mean that's been the overwhelming
feeling that I've had I'm over when
reaction is like you know people
stopping you and kind of going can't
wait to see what's going to happen
[Laughter]
my question exactly you guys left us off
with a fiery midseason finale in June it
looks like we lost Madison but on this
show you're never you know it's hard for
for fear the walking dead because it's
like you never really know if someone's
gone until you see the body we didn't
necessarily see that should fans just
assume Madison is gone I think I think I
should win a subset pretty Madison is
gone but also how Madison's death
propels all of our characters towards
some other new heights and new places to
go
yeah higher it shakes a ball in such a
way not just you know the clerics are
like strong but also the new cast too
like it's a human
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
Alicia and I on the show go through him
so much how is the death of her mom
going to affect your moving forward and
is this gonna make her questions well I
mean if we've seen her in a really
really dark place in the first half and
I can just say it's only gonna get worse
[Music]
you know she's lost she's the only
remaining Clark she's the only person
from the pilots still here like she's I
think I think has had one of the biggest
transformations out of anyone she's gone
from a teenage girl just like you know
regular teenage girl to now like her
entire family is gone and she's like a
warrior
yeah and now it's um yeah there's some
interesting thing stuff for her coming
up but we really just get to see her on
her own
completely and pretty marvelous to see
like what's it if you watch from the
beginning like what's happened to her
characters it is one of the things that
our show allows actors to do which a lot
of shows don't which is for their
characters to genuinely evolve their
characters to genuinely move from being
one thing to being something other and
it's something that I think is one of
the reasons why our Frant our fans that
are kind of compelled by what we do and
are attracted to us is because they have
ownership of the journey of our
character the change is dynamic it's not
subtle
it's like you really see human beings
experience life or death and how
transforms them and their character
changes their ideas change and their
actions change it's a dynamic experience
to behold so it's
and also watching Alisha - because I
come from the Mexico experience like
seeing her now dealing with this whole
entire season it was really hard for you
like she really like even as an actor
had to really confront this everyday
it's not like one episode as any of
those losses they're not just characters
that it's like we're having huge losses
you spend more time with yeah then your
family's fainting like you know 12-hour
day plus and then also you know getting
dinner afterwards like just catching up
to like kind of be there for one another
you are in each other's lives constantly
for seven months and days where I would
take the Atlanta heat over the smoke
it's like not quite the jackets like
long sleeves it's just like maybe I
don't need the jacket
whereas cars have you guys had any
favorite Walker kills oh we did oh I do
you do it's coming up with a little bit
yes there's a Walker kill that's coming
up pretty soon that involves yes deny
listening to some we were very involved
in that kill and then new problem that
was funny
well lastly what do you want to tease
for the fans as for what they can expect
when the Walking Dead returns on August
12th
well when fear the walking down that we
introduce a character and we're quite
long into the apocalypse now and we
introduce a character who's a newbie we
introduce a character who has not been
out into the world has not really come
across walkers and for the writers to
pull off bring in a newbie into this
world at this time I think is a real
stroke of genius and the particular
actor who plays that particular
character does a really romantic job so
I'm looking forward to the friends
seeing that someone who's actually new
to the world and wide-eyed there are
some very interesting pairings yep
loads that focus on characters and
pairings of characters so we wouldn't
expect that you wouldn't expect together
and you really get to then know those
people yeah yeah full episodes - it's
not a lot of back and forth it's great
mystery - I'm so excited thank you so
much cash we fear The Walking Dead the
series returns for second half of season
4 on August 12th